[Music]
Robert thank you so much for being here
with me I appreciate it so talk to me
about your founding story I want to hear
the whole history of bearbottom okay
yeah it's a long story so we started
about 10 years ago when I was in high
school I had the idea I had the
opportunity to go overseas with my
father who's been in the apparel
industry you know my whole life and I
saw like production and huge factories
producing for like some of the world's
largest Brands and just got that
exposure then I came home to Florida in
the middle of winter I needed some
shorts because it doesn't get cold there
and I couldn't find shorts that like
suited what I was looking for and at a
good price point and that's when I
talked to my dad I said you know what
does it cost to produce these you know
what's that look like got some more
information and I said how hard could it
be to sell shorts online right yeah so
that was my idea and then he said yeah
go ahead and try it not thinking I was
serious and about a year later I went I
interned in Hong Kong and like learned
about production and sourcing product
development and then built the website
got our first shipment of 10,000 pieces
and started selling shorts online from
then that's kind of the five minute you
know quick version of our
story you don't hear Too Many people say
that they started their company in high
school what made you think that you
could actually take that dive into
entrepreneurship so young I think part
of it was I was young you know I was
naive I just kind of thought how like I
said how hard could it be to sell shorts
online I was very naive but I started it
really when I was in college and I think
that was a real opportunity for me cuz I
didn't have too much pressure you know I
didn't I wasn't an adult I wasn't
looking for jobs I wasn't like doing
this as a side gig you know I was going
to class obviously and like having my
friendship and social life but outside
of that I was like all right let me
figure out how to sell shorts
online talk to me about the types of
clothes you you produce and who exactly
is your target market so we produce only
Men's Wear right now it's super
comfortable like daily clothing that you
wear so we have active we have like
casual Basics a lot of our customers are
people who like to get Outdoors who are
you know passionate about what they do
so we like to say everyday Adventure is
what we design for really whatever it is
like our product is made for
[Music]
you there's so many you know Menor
Brands out there today both in you know
just the e-commerce and the startup
scene like you but also incumbents that
have been around for years how are you
working to to stand out and make people
choose bare bottom over any others
definitely yeah we try to provide a lot
of value to our customers in both like
product quality and then customer
experience every single product review
we read our whole team reads our
customer service team responds to any
review that's not a fivestar review I
get emailed to me our coo gets emailed
to me we share those reviews and
feedback with our Factory so we really
do care a lot and like that's again what
it comes down to everyone on our team is
super passionate about our product and
making sure our customers you know get
the same experience that we want to have
as a customer with any other type of
brand now you're totally bootstrapped
which I think is really incredible have
you thought about taking on any outside
Investments or do you want to in the
future we've looked into it briefly but
you know we like how we can operate the
team without having like outside
influences we have some good mentors
that we're able to bounce ideas off of
and network within other brands who are
in the same space which is really cool
we like to have you know people who are
really competitors of ours they're
willing to share and we're willing to
share with them so I like that
relationship but right now we don't
really plan on raising any
funds and talk me about your sales
growth over the past few years yeah so
Co was really where we saw a huge Spike
we've grown consistently since I started
the business but after Co I really like
skyrocketed the first couple weeks were
really rough and then just was like a
really steady increase from there and
we've been growing ever
since can you share any of your Revenue
metrics or any other yeah so this year
we're expecting about $25 million in
Revenue wow so that's amazing congrats
thank
you is there any advice that you wish
you knew on day one of founding your
company that you'd give yourself now yes
definitely I would say like the biggest
lesson I wish I knew then is how
important it is to have a strong team
around you like once we started adding
like really good members to our team as
one in our business really started to
grow a lot and see the success we see
now and one final question for you
Robert what would you like your legacy
to be I think main thing for my legacy
would probably be like that we helped a
lot of people along the way whether we
help them grow our production partners
and you know for every item we sell
right now we donate a meal to a child in
need so we're going to soon surpass 1
million meals donated so I think as long
as you know people can remember us for
doing something like that I think
that'll be really
[Music]
awesome